comment ces raids sa mère j'en ai passé
des époques view d'ubs a dit vertes et
des pas mûres
il conjugue au présent dans 1 et
pourquoi sambre de ma vie j'ai eu
l'honneur de rencontrer mon maître
battre gibbs
c'est bien par contre et qui tous ces
gens une petite facile c'est des gens
qui me vénère tu crois que c'est le ring
à tampere c'est quoi si tu connais pas
le combat tu vas finir fort boyard au
début est ma meuf tweed allait bien ce
qui fait de vous rappeler des grosses
barres de rire au plus sur tous les
jours on n'arrêterait pas qu'un monsieur
puis elle a commencé en avoir man à
cause de mon passion que je ressemble à
une dépêche
alors ça a commencé est amplement la
fête du slip salut à toi c'est ta copine
quoi même quand on se faisait des petits
restaurants la moëlle et thé vert de man
et à bosch notés triple a sur la tête de
ma mère une touchante de métaux coups de
couteau à temps plein et sérieux pour
des frites comme ça bison
kiki gentille autres grandes entreprises
ne jouent pas
bienvenue sur inch'allah airlines notre
températures de 35 degrés à notre
arrivée à pattaya le bateau à moteur
ici c'est le paradis des cailleras
comment savoir si une lettre à l'éditeur
je prends mal au cul de jatte à e-loue
l3 et la personne ne se dit jamais
contrôler le ballon poitrine et est elle
fait pas du people are mais ça veut dire
un high tech vous présente ma part je
compte bien d'autres ont été mon amour
tu faire des gosses est temps ça dérange
pas les contaminer puisqu'elle à une
cadence fatigué mais mon frère toutes
les femmes ils ont des particularités
ben badi toi ta meuf avec les produits
que je vois pas là bien à une petite
table
à ce moment précis nous donc on sait
partir pour des vacances de ouf à
pattaya et lula ils pensaient qu'on
l'emmenait au pèlerinage à la mecque
alors forcément tout il allait pas se
passer comme prévu qu'on soit bien clair
3 je n'irai pas à cette foule
à
hees a retrouvé l'amour que tu connais
toi là tu réduis dame a déjà vu un un
vieux annoncé présent d'ailleurs pas
frères à part dans blanc je n'achète pas
de mains